[Music]
You can give me
I learned.
[Music]
actually
shaking.
Good job.
[Music]
Jessica,
>> what's up?
[Music]
Yes, of course.
I love
[Music]
what's going on.
Hello everybody. Welcome. Come on in.
Find a seat.
Um, my name is Valerie. My pronouns are
she, her, and also birthday girl cuz
today is my birthday.
Thank you. Thank you.
Um, besides that important announcement,
we have a couple other announcements.
We are having a chili cookoff. So, the
sixth anniversary of the table is coming
up in November.
And to celebrate, we're going to do our
annual chili cookoff and it's going to
be after service on November 2nd. Um, so
if you are interested in participating,
you can scan the QR code that should be
coming up on the screens behind me
shortly. and uh you can sign up with
your chili recipe.
Also, we're going to have a five loaves
service day. This is going to be
happening on December 6th. Going to be
from 9:15 to 12. They're asking all
volunteers that are interested to go
ahead and register by November 17th. Um
that way we have all the waiverss and
everything done ahead of time. So, if
you're interested, again, the QR code
whenever it pops up behind me, um you
can scan that and you'll be able to sign
up for the five loaf service day.
Um it could be a little bit anxious
coming into a church setting. Um also,
if you're a part of a disabil disability
community or maybe you feel a little
fidgety, we have some uh uh f fidgets
over here to my left. There's some
fidget toys, some coloring sheets, noise
cancelling headphones. Please feel free
to help yourself at any point during
service to any of that over there. We
just ask that you um whatever you use,
go ahead and return at the end of
service. And of course, if you always
need to take a break, step out, that's
always available as well, too.
These candles that are lit lit here to
the right of me are a sign of the
presence of Christ of fully divine and
fully human.
Now let us exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness
and simplicity.
sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and
adoration,
a place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
>> Thank you, Val. Happy birthday again.
>> Um, if you guys want to stand with us,
we're going to get started tonight. We
have a a smaller acoustic set, but I
always just love the simplicity
sometimes of just taking it back to like
bare bones and just remembering that um
it's not all the excess stuff that makes
church um meaningful. It's the people
that make up the community. It's the
connection that we have with this spirit
of love and divinity and forgiveness.
So, let's lean into that tonight. Let's
look for it. Um, let's welcome it in to
our hearts and our minds as we together
[Music]
through every battle. Through every
heart,
through every circumstance,
I believe you are my portal
and you are my portion.
You are my hiding place.
I
the true
the
[Music]
way
the truth is your name.
I
believe you are.
You are
sing through every blessing, through
every blessing,
through every promise,
through every breath I take.
Oh, I believe that you are provided.
You are protective.
You are the one I love.
I believe you are the way,
[Music]
the truth,
the love.
I believe we are the way
[Music]
the truth
I believe.
[Music]
It's a new horizon
and I'm set on you.
You meet me here today with mercies that
are new.
All my fears and doubts,
they can all come too because they can
stay alone. When I'm here with you,
it's a new ride.
I'm sitting on you.
You need me here today with mercies that
are new.
All my fears and doubts
they can all come to me because they
can't stand.
And I believe you are the way
the truth.
[Music]
I believe you are
the true
[Music]
You
said on
you.
[Music]
They can all come true because they
can't stay long. I believe you are the
way
to the truth and
the life of me. I believe you are the
way
the truth the end.
I believe.
>> All right, kiddos. Y'all are dismissed
to go to your classes with your
teachers, and they're going to meet you
right over here by these double doors.
[Music]
You guys have fun. Thank you kids
ministry for helping out love on our
kids and teaching them about the love of
Christ.
We are going to transition into the
prayers of the people. So you may follow
along on the screens and the sections
that are in red. You might have to look
over at this one right now. We got a
nice little sunburst going on over
there. Um the parts that are in red
we'll read out loud together. And then
we'll leave space in the middle for you
to name a person or a situation that
you're carrying heavy on your heart
tonight. And we just want to lift those
up before God together as a community
and believe that he is with us in our
pain, in our concern, um, in our
heaviness.
Jesus, for the city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So, we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
kept in our hearts. We pray to you that
they may have life and light, healing
and hope, peace and a deep sense of your
presence.
Amen.
[Music]
All my words for sure.
I got nothing new.
How could I express
all my gratitude?
I could sing these songs
as I often do.
Every song must stand
and you never do.
So I throw up my hands, praise you again
and again.
Cuz all that I have is a hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
And I know it's not much, but I'm
nothing else fit for a king
except for a heart singing hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
I've got one response.
I've got just one move.
With my arms stretched wide,
I will worship you.
Oh, so I throw up my hands and praise
you again and again.
Cuz all that I have is a hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
And I know it's not much, but I'm
nothing else before a king.
Except for a heart singing hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
Come on my soul. Oh, don't you get shy
of me. Lift up your song cuz you've got
a lion inside of those lungs. Get up and
praise the Lord.
[Music]
Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you get
shout me. Lift up your song cuz you got
a lion inside of those lungs. Get up and
praise the Lord.
Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you get
shy of me. Lift up your soul cuz you got
a light inside.
Get up and praise the Lord.
Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you shout
me. Lift up your soul. You got life
inside.
[Music]
Get up there and praise the Lord.
[Applause]
[Music]
So I throw up my hands,
praise you again and again.
[Music]
I know it's not
your heart single
hallelujah.
[Music]
You meet me on the mountain top.
You see me in the valley low.
There is no home without you here.
And I find you in the crowded thoughts.
You quiet all the question marks.
There is no space your love won't fill.
[Music]
I traded all my fear for peace of mind.
All my heaviness
for burdens
light.
This will be my song.
You are always good.
I'll sing it all day long.
When the day is through,
I am left with you.
are all
you are
always good.
I've set my eyes on perfect.
You'll finish what you started me.
My heart will be an offer.
Traded all my fear for peace of mind.
You took carelessness.
My bird is alive.
This will be my song.
You are always good.
Sing it all day long.
[Applause]
You are always good.
When my day is through,
I am living.
are always
[Music]
happy.
Sing
[Music]
[Applause]
me
singing
back
[Applause]
me.
You're singing back to me. You're
singing back. I traed all my fear for
me.
You took me as my
life.
This will be my song.
You are always good.
You are always
when the tears
through
I am left with you.
[Music]
Oh,
I can't help but hear the words from
that passage in Psalms that says, "Where
can I go from your presence?
If I make my bed in the depths, you are
there.
At the top of the mountain, you are
[Music]
God, at the end of all my frustrations
or struggles or confusion, questions,
the one thing I find to be constant is
that you never run out.
At the end of it, I'm left with you
and I have found you to be good.
[Music]
You have been faithful, God.
The fact that some of us are in this
room reminds us that you are faithful,
that you have rescued us, that you have
pursued us,
that you've thrown us lifeline after
lifeline,
God. And you leave space and room for
all of our mess, our stories, our
questions,
God. And you welcome them all under your
wings,
God. You make space at your table for
us.
And you just keep inviting us back. You
keep calling us back to yourself,
[Music]
to our true selves.
A child made in your image,
made in love.
[Music]
God, would we cling to that story?
You are always good.
and you will always be.
Thank you for being that kind of God,
that kind of mother,
that kind of father.
We want to trust you with our lives.
We want you to finish the story that you
began.
[Music]
have our hearts, God.
Help us to open them up to you
and the good work that you do in Jesus
name. Amen.
Would you guys turn to the person on
your right and left and say, "The peace
of Christ be with you." And then you may
be seated.
[Music]
Well, grace and peace. So good to be
with you all. Uh my name is Brett and
the pastor here. Pronouns he him. And uh
it's a joy. Yeah. A joy to welcome you,
be with you in this space. And as
always, that includes those joining us
online. Love y'all lots. And uh anyone
here tonight who's new to the community,
uh thank you for being with us. We know
it can just take a lot of courage to
come through those doors and you know
enter a space where you like don't know
people and uh can wor be worried if
they're going to like be judgy or
something. So just know um we're really
really glad that that you're here and uh
yeah and you've you've come on a uh a
good night because this is week two in
our series titled the end. It's just a
new beginning. And uh here at the table,
we tend to just rather than like avoid
kind of difficult theological, biblical,
thorny topics, we just jump right in.
We're just like here we go. And uh and
so this series, it's very much kind of
in that vein. And uh so basically the
last week was a sort of introduction. I
do kind of preach every sermon to where
it's like a standalone, you know, so you
won't you're not like lost or anything.
Um it does some of the series and this
one in particular does kind of build a
little bit. So I encourage you can go
back on the pod and like catch that if
you missed last week. Um but basically
in the kind of introduction I just made
the case that what many um
kind of you know progressive Christians
um believe esquetology to be or kind of
contrary to what we often think it to
be. Um which by the way esquetology
means like the doctrine of last things.
You know if you had to kind of sum it up
would be like the book of revelation. uh
at least in people's minds. It's really
only the very last chapters of that book
that actually have to do with last
things. But anyway, um so but there's
other sayings, you know, of Christ and
such which we'll get into. But kind of
contrary to how we often think of this
as like very just like it's just the
worst. It's just like negative doomsday,
you know, apocalyptic kind of theology.
Um uh but I want to kind of contend I
think it's actually a really powerful
and ultimately hopeful set of teachings
that we um that need to be rediscovered
and and yes kind of reunderstood
rethought in some ways. And
so and and kind of what we're trying to
rediscover there is really what's known
as the apocatasis which is a big fancy
theological word that just means the
restoration of all things. And because I
think because of that like that's is why
the Christian vision is radically like
hopeful and positive and beautiful. Um
now I just hinted at this last week. I
give like a paragraph on this subject.
And so this week I want to wade a little
bit more into I mean probably the
thorniest of all the the things. And if
you've been at the table for years,
you've heard me like I've done like
sermons here and there on this topic,
but I want to keep revisiting it because
I feel it's so important um that we
really um get clear on this notion of
like what what is you know hell and
judgment and you know all that like
what's what's going on there. And so
this week um I want to do a deep dive
into that topic. So uh with that in
mind, the title of my message specific
to this week is flame of love.
And
uh and we have two primary passages. Uh
both of them are the words of Christ
found in the Gospel of Matthew. Uh we
have one from Matthew 24 and one from
Matthew 25. They're a bit lengthy, but I
do I want to kind of, you know, set this
up and really kind of ground us in uh
the Bible and the words of Christ where
um we're as we approach this. So this is
Matthew 24 starting verses uh verse 27.
For as lightning that comes from the
east is visible even in the west, so
will be the coming of the son of man.
Immediately after the distress of those
days, the sun will be darkened and the
the moon will not give its light, the
stars will fall from the sky, and the
heavenly bodies will be shaken. Uh this,
by the way, this language, this is
what's known as apocalyptic literature,
uh which was like a genre. Right? It was
like a style of writing that was very
popular in what's known as the
intertestamental period, meaning the 400
years or so between like Old Testament,
New Testament. Uh, so it's it's it uses
very like hyperbolic
language. So it's not to be taken too
literally. I do think we should take it
seriously, but not necessarily
literally. In other words, you read like
the stars will fall from the sky, you
know, it's like like literally like,
"All right, I'm looking. Is it going to
happen?" You know, or the moon will be
turned to blood or, you know, it's like
okay. Um this is it's using I mean this
is where I think human language
ultimately is sort of failing right it's
trying to kind of give voice to these
like absolutely
cosmic
universe cosmos shattering events you
know that it's like the language kind of
fails here so we just reach for poetry
uh verse 30 then will appear the sign of
the son of man in heaven and then all
the peoples of the earth will mourn when
they see the son of man coming on the
clouds of heaven with power and great
glory he will send his angels with a
loud trumpet Paul and they will gather
his elect from the four winds from one
end of the heavens to the other. So
that's our first scripture. This is a a
description of what's known as the the
peruseia. We talked about this last
week, the return of Christ at the end of
this age. And what I'd like you to
notice, at least in this one, is that
this is a little bit different than
what's commonly referred to as uh the
rapture. So the idea of the rapture is
drawn from certain passages like this
one we just read, Matthew 24 and other
texts like 1 Thessalonians 4 uh verses
13 through 18, which talks about us
meeting Christ in the air. And then
certain Christians will combine those
texts with some ones from the book of
Revelation. And we'll say kind of like,
"Oh, okay. Okay. So we
uh the believers you know we escape
we escape you know like the judgment and
such and we fly away you know I'll fly
away the old him like I'll fly away but
then it'll go real bad for everyone else
um on earth and they'll you know have to
experience the the judgment life fly
away to heaven and uh you know to many
kind of modern Protestants that's just
like obvious you know it's just like
yeah it's just called the gospel you
know uh but it's actually that kind of
take on esquetology and timelines and
such is really uh a rather kind of
fringy interpretation it was basically
unknown in Christian history until about
200 years ago about 1800s or so and
really in the 1900s it like took off it
was like wildfire in Protestant circles
are like yes that's where you got really
like a lot of like end times kind of
stuff you know And uh now just to be
clear, I'm not saying the return of
Christ wasn't like popular taught. I'm
saying this idea of us like we fly away
and we escape, you know, and we leave
all those bad people to go through the
heart, you know, that's where it's kind
of like
this is not not quite. So instead, I
think a the more accurate picture is
what we're about to read. This is
Matthew 25 uh 31- 46. And personally,
it's one of my favorite passages in all
of scripture, though I must also admit I
find it deeply challenging. Um, even
kind of disturbing in ways um but kind
of like in a good way. Uh, and so this
is Matthew 25 beginning in verse 31.
When the son of man, that is Christ
comes in his glory. So you can see there
this connection with Matthew 24, right?
When Christ comes again and all the
angels with him. He will sit on his
glorious throne. All the nations will be
gathered before him. He will separate
the people one from another as a
shepherd separates the sheep from the
goats. He'll put the sheep on his right
and the goats on his left. Then the king
will say to those on his right, "Come,
come, you who are blessed by my father,
take your inheritance, the kingdom
prepared for you since the creation of
the world. For I was hungry and you gave
me something to eat. I was thirsty, you
gave me something to drink. I was a
stranger and you invited me in. I needed
clothes and you clothed me. I was sick
and you looked after me. I was in prison
and you came to visit me. Then
the righteous will answer him, 'Lord,
when when did we see you hungry and feed
you or thirsty and give you something to
drink? When did we see you a stranger
and invite you in or needing clothes and
clothe you? When did we see you sick or
in prison and go to visit you? The king
will reply, truly I tell you, whatever
you did for one of the least of these
brothers and sisters of mine,
you did for me.
Then he'll say to those on his left,
"Depart from me, you who are cursed,
into the eternal fire prepared for the
devil and his angels. For I was hungry
and you gave me nothing to eat. I was
thirsty, you gave me nothing to drink. I
was a stranger, you did not invite me
in. I needed clothes and you did not
clothe me. I was sick and in prison and
you did not look after me." They also
will answer, "Lord, when when did we see
you hungry or thirsty or a stranger or
needing clothes or sick or in prison and
did not help you?" He will reply, "Truly
I tell you, whatever you did not do for
in the least of these, you did not do
for me." Then they will go away to
eternal punishment, but the righteous to
eternal life.
This is a I mean, it's a fascinating
passage on like so many levels. I love
the the whole element of Christ in
disguise.
You know, that's the disturbing part
like these these folks that um so often
in society go ignored
uh u marginalized pushed to the edges
you know and it's like Christ is like
hiding so to speak in them Christ is
present even in them you know um also
the note the judgment by works
which is interesting and as you know
good protestants
a little uncomfortable
um because you know it's saved by grace
and yet it's interesting here it's a
judgment by works and notice too uh he
doesn't say and then you know on that
day I shall divide all of the people uh
and one group shall be the Christians
you know uh and then uh all the the
other group will all the the people of
all the other religions,
they shall be the goats and no that's
why I'm saying like this is disturbing
and I wonder if it's um I mean it really
should be preached I think more in
churches you know I mean like how kind
of but it's almost like we just kind of
glide over it or something you know
instead of naming like it's like oh my
goodness uh I mean it's it's discerning
he says he you know it will be about how
we lived right the actions of our lives
towards the poor, the marginalized, the
weak, the defenseless, the ignored, the
unloved. And why that? Because it's such
a revelation of the heart, you know,
just like reveals like what's what's
going on deep inside us. Now, that's
probably another sermon for another day.
For our purpose, what I want to zero in
on is this language of eternal
punishment because I think it's probably
texts like these this Matthew 25 in
particular um that very much come to
mind when you know say like last week
I'm preaching you know about the God who
is love and how actually you know
esquetology you know last things the
return of Christ and all this like this
is good news and I know
there are folks who are kind of thinking
to themselves like I yes I really like
this I am pretty sure somewhere though
Jesus talks about uh an eternal hell you
know maybe I can't quote it chapter and
verse right now but Brett I'm pretty
sure it's in there and if you just give
me a minute to uh Google it uh or maybe
chat gpt I don't know which one are
y'all doing y'all still googling maybe
some of your kids are maybe chatgt more
and I don't know, maybe not. Um,
whatever you do, right? But you're just
like, "Give me a minute and I will do
this search. I will I will find this
passage." And of course, right, it's
something like this. Matthew 25 or, you
know, would be a verse you would come
across. And um
and and what makes it challenging too is
um it's the words of Christ himself,
right? So, if you were here for my last
series on, um, the scriptures and such,
um, or kind of on the Bible in general,
um, there's no kind of getting around
this saying like, "Oh, well, that's the
Old Testament, you know what I mean?"
Or, "Oh, well, that's, um, that's not
the that's that's uh, not the Gospels."
Or, "Well, it's the Gospel. It's not the
words of Jesus." You know, you're like,
"Oh, no, no, here." It's like it's it's
the New Testament. It's the Gospel of
Matthew. It's the words of Jesus
himself, right? So how on earth can I be
hopeful about this this vision of you
know all things and such? Um well the
the reason is uh it's honestly it's
about the original language. So the
Greek word translated here as eternal is
uh actually much more flexible than uh
our English Bibles kind of let on. So
basically there's two Greek words
translated into English as eternal that
are found in in your Bible. Um now of
course the trick is right in English we
just see eternal but in the Greek that's
kind of the point right in the Greek
it's like actually two different ones.
So the first is adios and uh this means
forever eternal infinite. In classical
Greek it was used in connection with
things like um infinite straight lines
in mathematics or the kind of size of
the universe which some Greek
philosophers thought of as like infinite
or eternal uh in nature. So in the New
Testament though this word this one's
not very common. Uh it's used twice in
the New Testament, twice in the Greek
translation of the Old Testament, which
is originally written in Hebrew, but
it's called the Septuagen. It's like the
Greek translation, not very common
except for scholars to read it today. Um
so really the main ones are those two
two in the New Testament. So let me just
give you an example. This is like where
it's used in the New Testament. Um
Romans 1 chapter 1 verse 20. For since
the creation of the world, God's
invisible qualities, his eternal power.
So that's a idios eternal power and
divine nature been clearly seen being
understood from what has been made. So
people are without excuse. So that's
adioidios eternal forever infinite. Uh
the other Greek word used is uh it's
it's much like used a lot more in the
New Testament 71 times and it's ionas
and it means age, era, uh eon, epoch.
Here's how Marvin Vincent in his word
studies of the New Testament unpacks the
this the root word of ionios which is
ion. He says this ion transliterated aeo
n in English is a period of longer or
shorter duration having a beginning and
an end and complete in itself.
Aristotle for example right who of
course wrote and spoke Greek he says the
period which includes the whole time of
one's life is called the ion of each
one. Hence it often means the life of a
man as in Homer where one's life ion is
said to leave him or to consume away. It
is not however limited to human life. It
signifies any period in the course of
events as the period or age before
Christ, the period of the millennium,
the mythological period before the
beginnings of history. The word has not
a stationary and mechanical value. In
other words, it does not mean a period
of a fixed length for all cases. There
are as many ions as entities, the
respective durations of which are fixed
by the normal conditions of the several
entities. There is, for example, one ion
of a human life, another of the life of
a nation, another of a crow's life,
another of an oak's life. The length of
an ion depends on the subject to which
it is attached. So, I'll give you, you
know, three guesses, but you'll only
need one as to which Greek word is found
in Matthew 25, uh, and specifically in
verse 46 there, but it's used earlier as
well in the passage. So, you know, and
just imagine like, um,
how translations and how are how we
might think of like scripture and
Christian theology and such quite
differently if we were reading
translations like these. I'm going to
give you two. These are um translations
that are known for being as literal in
English and as faithful to the original
Greek as possible. However, they're very
kind of unpoetic and clunky, which is
why almost no like preacher reads from
these because they just don't read well,
smoothly, beautifully. Um but they are
known for being very literal. So here,
this is the first one. This is Young's
literal translation of Matthew 25:46.
And these shall go away to punishment
age daring, but the righteous to life
age daring,
which is a strange, you know what I
mean? It it you can see where it's super
clunky, right? Like age dear, you know,
I think it's kind of getting at like
ageing.
Uh here's another one. This is
Roderham's emphasized Bible. Uh, and
these shall go away into ageabiding
correction, but the righteous into
ageabiding life. Uh, you'll notice the
word correction there for the sake of
time. I'm not getting into that word in
this sermon. Uh, but again, the original
Greek is um translated into English as
like punishment. But it, you know,
suffice to say, it doesn't it doesn't
mean like torture.
you know the idea is correction or
chastisement.
Um which is why here in this you know
more literal translation it chose um
correction.
Now coming back to our main point about
this word eternal. Again, I just wonder,
you know, I wonder how Christian
theology would be different if we were
reading from these types of translations
that were using terms like age or age
abiding or eon rather than eternal. You
know, I'm I'm imagining, for example,
like a uh you know, a hellfire and
brimstone preacher who was like raised
on Young's literal translation. You
know, I wonder like how that would
influence their preaching. You know what
I like if you don't get your life right,
you're going to hell
for a little while,
you know, like it for
maybe even for a short time. We aren't
really sure. It's, you know, it's
unclear. All right. But the the point is
you'll go there and you'll be chasened,
corrected, healed, restored, made whole
until until you have the original glory
with which you once shown. You know what
I like it's just like what the this is
what is going on with this kind of
um I just yeah it loses all of the punch
but uh but I think it changes it in a
good way. So like in short to kind of
sum all this up, I would say I think
really the concept of hell understood
specifically as like eternal retributive
justice
uh rather than an ion, an epoch, an era
and age, a season of restorative
justice.
I think that's done like very profound
damage to people's relationship to God
and to uh the Christian faith as a
whole. You know what what happened was
we we got in this weird
thing where it was like this split in
God, you know, where it's like God is
love, but if you don't believe, he's
going to torture you forever. You know,
it's just like this str like we really
kind of came to see God as a bit of a a
monster to be appeased rather than as a
loving and righteous judge who will do
right by us and all creation.
Now, what do I mean right by? Do right
by? Well, I I think what I'm getting at
here is coming back to that Matthew 25
passage and it's really extremely
convicting language and it's, you know,
judgment by works. you know, um I think
this is where Christ's return is good
news,
but it's not necessarily easy news,
you know, like I wonder if uh people,
especially people who don't attend the
table, but just kind of know me vaguely
from my occasional, you know, or my
social media posts or something. I
wonder if they think like, you know,
Brett's one of those wimpy progressive
Christians. They're just like all, you
know, God's all loveydovey and not at
the end of all things. He just pats all
of humanity on the bottom. You know,
even dictators and, you know, serial
killers and he just says, "Oh, come on
in. You've been bad, but it's okay." You
know, like this is what grace is all
about. You know,
[Music]
not exactly. That's what um the
Protestant theologian Derrick Bonhofer,
he called that cheap grace,
and he railed against it. He said, uh,
chief grace, it's grace without
repentance.
You know, it's grace without
disciplehip. It's grace without
transfiguration and transformation.
It's grace without judgment. Right now,
you're thinking like, but again, I
thought you're a nice preacher.
Judgment. Well, again, I'm not talking
about like judgment as in payback, like
God's going to get you. You can't wait,
you know, like no, no, no. Um,
no. justice in the sense of really it's
the it's the refining fire of God's
love. It's this flame of love. The
wonderful theologian Sergius Bulgakov,
he put it this way. He said, "This
encounter with God, this entering into
the realm of the divine fire, it's not
something optional for human beings. It
is inevitable."
He says, "For some, this is the time of
liberation.
Look up. Lift up your heads. Luke 21:28.
For others, it is a time of fear and
horror. Then shall all the tribes of the
earth mourn, and they shall see the Son
of Man coming in the clouds of heaven
with power and great glory. No one can
avoid this encounter, for it is not an
outward encounter, but an inward one.
For many, this will be an unexpected and
undesired transformation of their being.
For the transfiguration,
the light of glory given to human beings
can do more than illuminate. It can also
consume in fire.
You see, I believed I believe we're all
saved by grace. And I really do believe
that like in the end, love wins. God
will heal and restore every single one
of us. But as Matthew 25 says, we will
stand before the God who is love.
And we will have to answer for our sins
against love. We will be tested by that
refining fire.
The passage I always return to when
preaching on all this is 1 Corinthians
3:es 11-15. Paul writes this, "For no
one can lay any other foundation other
than the one already laid, which is
Jesus Christ." Right? That's the grace
part. We're all building a life on this
foundation of Christ. He continues, "If
anyone builds on this foundation using
gold, silver, costly stones,
or wood, hay, or straw, their work will
be shown for what it is."
Because what? The day, capital D, right?
Not just any other day. It's like
Matthew 25 day, the day of the Lord. It
will bring it to light.
You know, so often we're eaten up with
the injustices of the world. We just
can't stand it. It's just like driving
us crazy. You know, no one gets away
with anything.
It will be revealed with fire. And the
fire will test the quality of each
person's work. If what has been built
survives,
the builder will receive a reward.
If it is burned up, the builder will
suffer loss.
but yet will be saved
even though only as one escaping through
the flames.
In other words, I kind of imagine
us kind of walking through that refining
fire
and I I really believe so many of I mean
I know y'all's hearts like we have so
many good-hearted people here. I really
believe you're going to come through
that fire just radiating with the glory
and the beauty and the goodness of God
just glowing, right? Because your life
not perfect, but it's a it's a beautiful
and a Christlike one.
Uh but there's others, right? Those who
lived like absolute hell, just bringing
hell to earth. I I I think um not to
pick on them, but I think again we were
at North Texas Pride a week ago on
Saturday and I mentioned the protesters
who were out there protesting the the
drag queens and the you know they had
the megaphone just trying to wreck the
event and literally I mean just spewing
you know hatred and venom and and their
own kind of you know judgment and I mean
you can see the irony
right Ironically they're telling ing
others in their own pride and
self-righteousness.
You all, you're going to hell. I mean,
that's the great irony. They're not
thinking through the fact that they too
are going to pass through that living
flame of love. And everything in their
life that is not of love,
it will burn away.
It will burn away.
And they just may come out looking like
soot.
So little of their life
made of quality, made of something that
can pass through the fire. But you know
what? The grace of God can save even
them.
And I believe he will.
So I think the the question for us is
how open am I
to that living flame of love
doing its work in me today.
That's that's the question, right?
Because I really do believe this
spiritual fire, again, I know all the
theology in the background on it, it's
all been terror and the demons are going
to be poking you with hot, you know, if
everyone went to like the house of
judgment or the hell houses or all sorts
of just stupidity, you know. Um, so we
got to kind of get that out of our
heads. But I really do believe this
spiritual fire, it's good news, right?
Uh, it's the purifying fire of God's
love. It's good news.
Because I don't know about you, but I
want to be free.
I want to be free. I want to be healed.
And so, I think Christians really should
be praying every day, Lord, bring the
fire of your love upon me. Even here and
now. Bring your fire upon me. I don't
want to wait for the day of the Lord. I
want even here and now to be purged,
cleansed, healed, restored, transfigured
today
as far as is possible in this life. Oh
God, do that work in me today.
And then we trust. We trust that the God
who is love will do exactly that. That's
good news. In the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it. Eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." And then he held up a cup of
wine. He said, "Take this drink. This is
my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me."
And so for thousands of years now,
Christians have gathered at the table to
receive again Christ, to receive his
grace, to receive his love and
forgiveness and healing. So uh as you
come forward tonight, I pray it can be
in that kind of spirit, you know, an
openness to receive the goodness uh of
God into your own heart and mind. So,
the way we'll um participate in
communion tonight in just a moment, a
few people will come forward to serve
and then we'll just go row by row
starting here at the front and kind of
working our way back and we'll just form
one line here in uh in the middle. You
should know that um the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. Uh and then we
practice an open table. I mean, if
you're here tonight and you'd like to
participate, then you are welcome to do
that. uh regardless of your exact like
theology or denomination or you know
something um you're you're welcome to
come to the table. Also, you can uh
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks like to come and kneel here
at the front. Uh some partake
immediately. Uh some return to their
seats to partake, but no one will lead
you through the exact moment. You can
just kind of do that as you uh as you
feel led. So this is the table not of
the church but of the Lord. And it's
made ready for those who love him and
for those who want to love him more. So
come. So come you who have much faith
and you who have little. You who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long. You who have tried to
follow and you who feel like you failed.
Come. Come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you. And it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
We're going to close tonight with a song
that you guys are welcome to just sit
back and soak. in the lyrics. Um, it's
called Runaway. And funny enough, I did
not like go looking for this song. It
was kind of one of those Spotify days
where you just have like a radio channel
playing and suddenly I was like, "Oh my
gosh, whatever song is playing right
now, I know this, but it's from a
child's book that I read to my kids,
like when they were babies." Um, if any
of you are familiar with Margaret Weiss
Brown, she was like a popular children's
author. And she wrote good night, goodn
night moon, which is really popular, and
another book called Runaway Bunny. And I
got to be honest, I am a little burned
from this book because the more I read
it to my kids, like child after child, I
have four kids. There was a lot of
Runaway Bunny in our lives. So, the more
I read it, I was like, I I think I have
a problem with this book. feels a bit
like a manipulative parent that like
cannot part or separate from their own
child as they grow. Like this this bunny
keeps saying, "Well, I'm going to run
away." And the mom's like, "Fine, do
whatever you want. I'm just going to go
find you and I'm going to drag you back
home." That's how I was hearing it after
multiple readings, you know, for years
and years. And I was like, "I think this
is unhealthy." But I I listened to this
song and and it really was it was a
beautiful song. And me and Brett had
been having all these conversations
about this series because I'm still
unpacking this whole theology that I
grew up with hell and now there's Greek
words that I didn't even know existed,
you know, and he's always teaching me
things. So, he has his Inagram five
moments and I just sit there and try my
best to soak in as much as I can from
all these different words. And it
reminded me of this song as he's talking
about this this pursuing love that's
constant like it keeps going. It's not
like there's, you know, an end to the
story. It just keeps loving us. It keeps
changing us. It keeps doing its work.
And I talked to Harper about it, my
14-year-old, and I was like, I want to
do this song, but I'm struggling with it
because I am like kind of feeling like
the manipulative side of some versions
of love are still stuck in my head. And
Harper goes, "I think this is really
just about no matter what you do, no
matter what you've done, the love is
still going to be there." And I was
like, "Oh, that's a simple way to
interpret it." Like, sometimes you just
need to hear someone else like say it
simply and you get out of all the
questions and confusion in your head to
be able to just accept this simple
message of the constancy of this divine
love that we were made with. So running
away from it would be like running from
the very nature of God's love that he
imparted into us. And so I just wanted
to read that passage real quickly that I
referred to earlier. It's in Psalm 139
and then we'll get started on this song.
It says, "Where can I go from your
spirit? Where can I flee from your
presence? If I go up to the heavens,
you're there. If I make my bed in the
depths, you're there. If I rise on the
wings of the dawn, if I settle on the
far side of the sea, even there your
hand will guide me. Your right hand will
hold me fast. If I say, "Surely the
darkness will hide me, and the light
will become night around me. Even the
darkness will not be dark to you. The
night will shine like the day. The
darkness is as light to you. For you
created my inmost being. You knit me
together in my mother's womb.
My frame was not hidden from you. When I
was made in the secret place, your eyes
saw me.
When I awake, I am still with you.
Search me, oh God. Know my heart. Test
me. Know my anxious thoughts. See if
there's any offensive way in me. And
lead me in the way everlasting.
[Music]
I
can see it in your eyes
that you're going to run.
You're going to run.
And I
can hear it in the way
that you speak to me
that you're going to leave.
As
you slip away,
I will say
[Music]
you pack your things.
I will see.
Even if you run away from me, over the
mountains, through the valleys, I will
not rest, but search east and west to
bring you back with me. And even if you
sail away from me across the
seas,
I will move again like the mighty wind
and blow you back to me.
I'm going to move again like the mighty
wind and blow you back to me.
[Music]
And I
have seen this all before.
It is all too
familiar.
[Music]
But you
will never see the botm of
the store houses
[Music]
of my love.
So as
you use the night
to make your flight,
[Music]
no choice
that you will make
[Music]
or path you take
will change my mind.
And even if one day you decide, you will
find somewhere else to hide, I will walk
your way and call your name and wait for
your reply.
Even if you make up in your mind, you
don't want to be back by my side, I will
leave behind the 99.
Oh, that you'd be mine.
I'm going to leave behind the 99.
[Music]
[Laughter]
Even if you stomp and scream and huff,
tell me that I'm not good enough.
I'll take every swing and every blow
until you know my love.
Even if you beat upon my chest, tell me
that you don't understand.
I will love you and teach you to love me
again.
I'm going to love you and teach you to
love me again.
[Music]
Thanks so much for joining us this
evening.
Um, if you're new, we would love for you
to fill out a card on the table that's
right over here on your way out. Or you
can also scan the QR code that's right
up there behind me. Um, we just let you
know that you are here.
We can all use more relational support.
Hi, Finley.
Um, and spiritual connection. The way
that we do this at the table is through
our meetup groups. Um, if you're not a
part of a meetup, you can scan the QR
code and you'll find one that works well
for your location.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship. If the the table
is your church home, then we would
invite you to scan the QR code and you
can give financially or you can also
give by visiting the tablet tx.org.
Now, most importantly, as I said at the
beginning, it is my birthday today. And
I have cupcakes outside. What do we call
this? Foyer. Foyer area. I've got
cupcakes outside in the foyer area. So,
if you know me or you do not know me,
please go out there and have a cupcake
in honor of my birthday.
[Music]
And let's on and if you really want a
cupcake, you should go quickly because
I'm sure once the kids get out, they're
going to be grabbing them. So,
okay,
let me spend us out into our week with a
benediction.
You can hold your hands out in a posture
to receive or you can just open your
heart to these words.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it is
true on your worst day.
So, as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between, go filled
with assurance that you are loved,
you are worthy,
and you are accepted exactly as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you meet.
Thank you.
[Music]
>> I'm not good enough.
I'll take every swing and every blow
until you know my love. Even if you beat
upon my chest, tell me that you don't
understand.
I will love you and teach you to love me
again.
I'm going to love you and teach you to
love me again.
[Music]